this this event is one that's been made
possible by by a few people I feel
duty-bound to acknowledge but I'm also
delighted to do that I want to
acknowledge Arnold Saltzman above all
it's simply because you know it's his
Institute that in sponsoring this this
lecture has really provided us with the
wherewithal to make it all work
but then alongside him I want to also
acknowledge in spirit at least alongside
and Roger her talkin that created the
Hertog global strategy initiative and
this lecture is the first in a series
that will take place under those
auspices let me just say something
briefly about what this is all about the
Hertog global strategy initiative is is
meant to create a kind of laboratory
kind of laboratory for historical
research that can help us think about
new approaches to some of the most
pressing problems in world politics in a
way it's it's what happens when you blow
the walls down in the university and try
to build something completely new in
order to find out you know who are the
people
what's the skillset we need to bring
together for a summer to work on these
problems this year the problem is going
to be the history and perhaps the future
of nuclear proliferation next summer
we're looking at the history of public
health preparations for the next
pandemic but this program it's in itself
a little bit like a nuclear bomb in that
it has different components it's not
just that we blow the walls down it's
also got different pieces to it this
lecture series is at the very core of
this initiative but there's also been a
workshop we're coming fresh from that
workshop where Hans Blix spent the whole
day advising our students and how to
orient their research he was joined
there by a lot of the the leading
experts in there are also classes
under Steffensen is teaching of course
this summer on the cold war we have a
seminar that runs alongside this lecture
series for those of you interested in in
in-depth discussions about the work of
the speakers it will take place every
Thursday between 4:00 and 6:00 and and I
could say other things about it but I
just invite you to have a look at our
website which says says much more um
hans blix it was a man you know who as
we all know made history and I think
that's one reason why he cares so much
about about how we study it he can bear
witness to the tragic consequences when
international law fails to reflect the
world as it is were suffice in itself to
change that world so he's there for the
perfect person I think to inaugurate the
hertog lectures and in global strategy
jean-marie que no I I think probably
would rather I say very little about him
to leave him more time to speak about
his old I think share is my goal in
wanting to make Colombia a center
perhaps the Center for the study of the
history and future of global governance
I think it would make sense that
Colombia be the place where we can begin
to write that history and maybe even
change it so you know he comes also as
somebody who who made history he was the
director of policy planning in the
French Foreign Ministry from there he
went on to many high-level positions in
the United Nations most recently he was
the undersecretary general for
peacekeeping operations during a period
that witnessed largest expansion and the
deployment of UN peacekeepers all over
the world there are now a hundred
thousand forces in the hundred thousand
troops in the field now we're professor
of professional practice and
international and public affairs so with
with no further ado let me turn things
over to jean-marie and thank you again
for coming
and a great pleasure to introduce hands
break and I must say that we at the
Arnold's house managed city warranty
studies we're very pleased that this
event can take place and I want to
acknowledge the presence are no salesmen
with us today thank you sir
hans blix you know his biography after
being the foreign minister Sweden you
it will soon be 30 years that you've
been working on on nuclear matters and
on fighting the the spread of nuclear
weapons and working for nuclear
disarmament you started as the director
of the International Atomic Energy
Agency I would say transforming that
agency in in many ways making it a body
that now all the world looks at form in
serious and credible verification and
many other activities and then you you
are very well known and not referred to
that for what you did as the chairman of
the executive chairman of inuvik and you
didn't stop there because when you left
the United Nations you chaired the
Commission and weapons of mass
destruction to work on real so that the
word would be rid of will get rid of
nuclear weapons and all weapons of mass
destruction so there is no better expert
to discuss the topics at hand today but
for me I must say that's not what
matters most
what matters is
what I remember as a UN civil servant in
the run-up to the Iraq war I remember
meeting you several times at the end of
very long days when the building was
almost deserted and you were still there
doing your an impossible task and you
were the owner of what an international
civil servant represents I I cannot but
think of your illustrious compact yet
daga Marshall do you who said with I
don't know a mix of Swedish dry humor
and understatement
I read in the the biography of Brian
Urquhart that he once said yes when the
UN yes the other servants of member
state but their servant should at the
right moment tell his master a little
bit about what he thinks about the right
development and I think you told more
than a little bit because your loyalty
and again I'm quoting them diagonal was
to the UN daga Marshall said though
there should be only one loyalty and
that is the one to United Nations
so in those very difficult moments when
the concept of an international
organization and an international civil
servant was really at stake you gave us
all hope and I would end on one last
quote of daga Marshall who said if the
International Civil Service was to fail
that would be the munich of
international cooperation he said that i
think 10 days before his death
in a speech to un staff well thanks to
you we know that that did not happen and
you you are an inspiration for all those
who believe that serving in
National Organization is in a way ahead
of it still very much ahead of its time
and your work has had a lot of meaning
because of that and you are very engaged
today in in issues that are discussed as
we speak at the United Nations as when
the NPT review conference comes to an
end that are discussed at the United
Nations as in the Security Council
considers what to do about Iran about
Korea North Korea you are going to talk
about those issues with the car with the
moderation the integrity that earned you
so much respect so thank you for being
here today thank you very much Matt
thank you very much John Murray for
those kind introductory words reminding
you that my function at the UN otherwise
I'm mostly known in the world for my
participation or appearance the team
America
I'm very pleased to be invited to
Columbia University to talk about
nuclear disarm the non-proliferation
this is in as in other areas a critical
thinking is vitally important when
discussing nuclear disarmament and
universities are the right places for
critical thinking
I remember the saying that I admire
those who search for the truth and I'm a
little worried about those who have the
truth I had the great privilege to be a
student at Columbia University in the
law school in 1954 to 1956 and I'm a
grateful pupil of distinguished
professors like Philip Jessup tan Oliver
the seats in the Ellen Goodrich Wolfgang
Friedman and my friend dick Gardner I
remember them with warmth and with
admiration as a student I learned about
the prohibition of use or particularly
horrible weapons like the dum-dum bullet
it is in the tradition of these rules
that we now discuss bands that aim at
the reduction and eventual elimination
of nuclear weapons no weapons no use
I also learned about the other approach
to avoid the use of weapons all weapons
namely the legal limitations of the use
of force no war no use of weapons in
this regard we should note that the
charter of the UN has outlawed the
threat or use of force between states
and made exceptions only for two cases
the self-defense against armed attacks
an armed force authorized by the
Security Council these restrictions on
the use of armed force stood at the
center of the legal objections to the
war that was waged in Iraq ostensibly to
eliminate weapons of mass destruction
they mark these provisions marked
momentous development in the
international community the more so as
their enforcement was backed by the
creation of the Security Council
with broad power to intervene if need be
even by military power admittedly in the
Charter restrictions on the use of force
have often been violated and the
Security Council has been paralyzed to
do it during much of its life on the
other hand the security system has been
complemented by peacekeeping operations
and the newer practice of peace building
and I am happy to acknowledge that in
the prisoners rosanna you know
so successfully headed the peacekeeping
and built it up for many years and how
Marshall began it originally with a
serious affair we should note that the
number of Interstate Wars in the world
seems to be going down the accelerating
interdependence of States creates
impediments to resort to weapons and
incentives to accommodation and to the
use of common institutions this larger
picture should be kept in mind when we
discuss nuclear non-proliferation and
disarmament the drive against nuclear
weapons should not be a solitary action
but rather form in my view a central
part of efforts to move towards a world
that is gentler and with better
organization for security for all we
should also not forget that reduction in
conventional weapons desirable in itself
sometimes have a direct in importance
for nuclear arms control and that the
small caliber weapons are today the real
weapons of mass destruction these are
the ones that crave the greatest number
of lives at the present time the title
of my presentation is movement toward a
new nuclear weapon-free world it is
intentional I do not do agree that the
complete elimination of nuclear weapons
the global zero is a desirable goal and
that it may indeed be wise to put it in
focus to gain broad public support much
I do not think that it is hopelessly
naive
some people say between 1910
and 1950 there were two world wars and
one collapsed World Organization much
can happen between 2010 and 2015 the
friend of mine said that a world without
nuclear weapons will not be simply like
the world the world we have today -
nuclear weapons nevertheless I shall
deem it my discussion largely to what we
can do in the short and medium term
rather than looking far into the future
during the Cold War their Arsenal's of
nuclear warheads increased to a
staggering 50,000 plus and most measures
to reduce the threats were fragmentary
such as agreements on the stopping of
atmospheric tests which other a
beneficial environmental effect or
rather avoiding the further fallout of
nuclear material and the second area of
fragmentary reforms were bans or the
stationing of nuclear weapons in their
environment such as the seabed and outer
space by contrast to these fragmentary
weapons the non-proliferation treaty
that entered into force in 1970 may be
read as aiming at the elimination of all
nuclear weapons the nuclear weapon
States committed would commit themselves
to stay away from non-nuclear weapon
States to stay away from nuclear weapons
and the five nuclear weapon states would
commit themselves to do away with their
nuclear weapons by negotiating towards
nuclear disarmament and agreements on
nuclear disarmament and lastly the
transfer of nuclear material and
technologies would be facilitated
between the parties to the NPT if all
states had adhered to the treated and in
all states had fulfilled their
commitments the world would have been
free of nuclear weapons the treaty has
evidently failed to achieve this aim
nevertheless we can note that nearly all
states have adhered which may which what
was by no means given when the treaty
was concluded further and that the
number of states with nuclear weapons
has increased by only
for since 1970 that the number of
nuclear weapons has gone down from over
50,000 plus to something like 20,000
plus and that indeed the international
market and technical assistance has
effectively facilitated the access to
the peaceful uses of nuclear energy
why has the number of nuclear weapons
days gone up but increased only by four
it's due to a number of circumstances
and I shall not list them all but I'd
like to mention that it's been suggested
that the bipolarity
of the world during the Cold War somehow
helped to hinder proliferation and that
the world is now facing the risk of
cascades of states and perhaps
terrorists developing nuclear weapons I
do not share this are alarmist view most
states refrain from acquiring nuclear
weapons simply because they do not
perceive a security need for them while
Cascades are improbable we do have
reason to be worried that security
concerns could raise the risk of Domino
effects in the Middle East and there
would be a rather slow there considering
who could develop nuclear weapons in
addition to Iran Israel and secondly
Domino facts could occur a plane in the
Far East if North Korea were to continue
and give rise to pressure give rise to
pressures in South Korea and Japan so
here are two areas obviously Domino
effects of of the Iran and North Korea
now if perceived security concerns is
the dominant incentive to acquire
nuclear weapons acting efforts to reduce
or eliminate such concerns should
logically be the first line of
non-proliferation policy and this was
indeed the view of the 2003 European
Union strategy against proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction and I quote
them they said that the best solution to
the problem of proliferation of weapons
of mass destruction is that countries
should no longer feel the need for them
if possible political solutions should
be found to the problems
which lead them to seek weapons of mass
destruction the more secure countries
field the more likely they are to
abandon programs the European recipe is
easy to support but sometimes difficult
to use and to apply where the government
appears to feel a security need for a
nuclear weapon we must ask if it's
security concern cannot be met by by
other means we also need barriers to
make the acquisition of or development
of nuclear weapons more difficult to
anyone tempted to try there be less
export restrictions are meant to be one
such barrier against those who might be
tempted to go for nuclear weapons and
the Security Council resolution 1540
obliges all Member you and Member States
to enact enact such restrictions which
is a novelty almost a sort of embark
embarking upon a legislative function of
the Security Council which was always
thought of as the an institution that
intervenes ad hoc and they see a threat
to the peace here they are urging with
demonical Member States that they should
enact legislation for in death--it
number of cases the Nuclear Suppliers
group evidence they also seek to rally
support exports care capable countries
to follow similar lines of action to
avoid the helping any proliferation the
enforcement of export bans through
interception of Trance forces sought
under the proliferation Security
Initiative and the UN Security Council
resolutions now it is hard to assess
just how important these approaches have
been to impede proliferation they
certainly have that the intention behind
them has had been to achieve this
economic sanctions are used to
discourage proliferation they have a
mixed record in the case of Libya
it seems that years of sanctions did
help to create an effective pressure and
sanctions may have given some incentives
to North Korea and Iran to comply with
UN secure
council yet these incentives have
evidently been so far not led to any
contain a result there could even be
some questions whether they inspire
defiance safeguards verification is
designed to stop but not designed to
stop proliferation but is more is more
than just a confidence-building measure
the risk of detection of two safeguards
to is intended to deter from diversion
of nuclear material and other violations
inspectors are not police dogs but they
are watchdogs they bought that they
don't bite nevertheless like watchdogs
they alert masters to take action now
let me talk about non peaceful means of
Plenty proliferation for moment acts of
sabotage to block the development of
nuclear weapons were undertaken even
before the first nuclear bomb was tested
in a daring raid a plant on a plant for
the production of heavy water the plant
was blown up in the occupied Norway to
impede Nazi Germany's development of a
nuclear weapon as the action took place
during the Second World War it clearly
fell action fell within the laws of war
in more recent times the concept of
counter proliferation has been advanced
comprising a wide spectrum of actions to
impede the development of nuclear
weapons including the destruction of
nuclear equipment through sabotage and
assassination of nuclear scientists such
actions may be carried out outside the
context of war they made violate
international law in the best known case
the bombing of the Iraq's research
reactor or Zurich in 1981 Israel was
condemned by the Security Council and
Israeli bombing in nineteen to into 2007
on the other hand on an allegedly
nuclear installation under construction
in al-qaeda in Syria that did not result
in a similar reaction in the council nor
have media to my knowledge
about have media reports about sabotage
directed against Iran's nuclear
enrichment program provoked any legal
discussion can states them legally
undertake armed intervention and destroy
life and equipment in peacetime if they
judge that such action will impede the
potential adversaries development of a
nuclear weapon the u.s. national
security strategy or 2002 does not
assert that this is the law that seems
to think that it should be the law their
strategy claims that for very long time
international law has allowed States to
defend themselves against forces that
present an imminent danger of attack an
imminent a danger of attack and it
argues that that concept should be
adapted to the capabilities of today's
adversaries and I quote the greater the
threat the greater is the risk of
inaction and the more compelling the
case for taking anticipatory action to
defend ourselves even if uncertainty
remains as to the time and place of the
enemy's attack to forestall or prevent
such hostile acts by our adversaries the
United States will if necessary act
preemptively it says nothing about
whether they think they believe that
other countries would have been entitled
to take the same action the UN Charter
that I quoted at the outset of this
lecture recognizes the right of
self-defense against an armed attack and
many interpreters of the Charter are of
the view that this right extends to
imminent attacks as well however to
equate the building of a research
reactor that could be of use in a future
production of weapons-grade plutonium
with an imminent attack would evidently
be a stretch and the u.s. security
strategy of 2002 does not do that
without even mentioning the UN Charter
the strategy simply argues the case for
action in some situations that lie
beyond the limb
currently drawn even under the liberal
interpretation of the UN Charter now
where does the Obama administration
stand on the on these questions the new
security strategy which I think will be
made public here this week if not
already public has been reported to be
more restrained than that of 2002 and
less unilateralis if so I think it will
be welcomed around the world as there
were no nuclear weapons or other weapons
of mass destruction in Iraq the case
illustrates the risk of the doctrine
allowing preventive armed action against
alleged threats if conclusions about
potential and potential adversaries
intentions are wrong because of the
erroneous intelligence or bad judgment
the doctrine leads to meaningless
bloodshed it is striking that in the
lively discussion about Iran the
question of the legality of armed action
against the Iranian enrichment
facilities hardly ever raised we can be
sure that the Security Council will not
authorize such action it would amount to
allowing an armed intervention against
alleged and denied intentions it is
improbable that any member of the
Security Council would even table a
resolution to that effect armed action
against Iran can also hardly be taken
under the UN recognize the right of
self-defense speeches that Israel should
be wiped off the map or condemnable but
amount neither to an actual attack armed
attack nor an attack that is imminently
a justifying preemptive action there is
nevertheless a risk of preventive action
that it might be taken to avoid the
somewhat distant risk of Iranian martyr
of an Iranian mushroom cloud I think
it's likely that the dire political and
economic consequences will stand in the
way of such action the valid legal
objections would be sustained that they
would not constitute the major factor
before I discuss the normal non-military
avenues in the Iran question that we
know some basic matters relating to Iran
question an industrial scale capability
to enrich uranium allows the production
of low enriched uranium for power
reactors as well as highly enriched
uranium for weapons you can produce to
3% you can produce Iranian uranium to a
93 percent having developed a capability
to enrich uranium the country may not
need much time to develop a weapon if it
wants one suspicion about Iran's
intentions in this regard have raised
the political temperature in the Middle
East and prompted severe controversies
at the political level there have long
been two diametrically opposed positions
Iran asserts that it is only exercising
a right under the NPT to the peaceful
use of nuclear energy including
enrichment and the UN Security Council
and the states negotiating with Iran so
are so far unconvinced that all parts of
the nuclear program had only peaceful
purposes and they demand in particular
that Iran shall suspend its enrichment
program now some facts and
circumstantially
although Iran has not been accused of
diverting nuclear material or violating
in the NPT and all they're not all
suspicions navigations may be
well-founded there is enough to lead a
large number of governments including
those of the p5 to urge Iran to suspend
the enrichment program the enrichment
program can hardly be prompted by
economic interest
Iran has so far only two nuclear power
reactors with fuel supply guaranteed by
Russia Sweden my own country with 10
nuclear power reactors finds the import
of enriched uranium more economic than
the indigenous production of India's
enrichment South Korea with 20 nuclear
reactors also rely upon the import of
enriched uranium
finding it less expensive than
indigenous production an Iranian desire
for uranium fuel independence would be
understandable but an indigenous
enrichment capability would not bring
such independence Iran is reported to
have only limited deposits of natural
uranium resources and would be obliged
to import uranium oxide yellowcake in
the long run anyway
Iran often evokes the right under the
empathy to enrich uranium as a reason
for refusing to discuss suspension
however the Treaty of the NPT imposes no
obligation to enrich tolerances
permission to do it yes but an
obligation No if Iran were to find that
unbalanced suspension of enrichment
would be to its advantage there is
certainly no legal of the objection or
bar obstacle to it in striking a deal
now it is conceivable that no offers or
threats from the outside world would
impact on Iran cost-benefit analysis for
the enrichment program nevertheless
negotiations often start with opposed
adamant positions and the way to learn
whether or not positions and lines are
immutable is through negotiations in my
view President Obama deserves praise for
allowing the United States to engage in
direct talks with Iran rather than
continuing the backseat driving a rather
haughty position that serious
negotiations including the United States
could only come as a reward for Iran
giving way on the main point by
suspending enrichment now which
negotiator gives up a trump card before
even sitting down to play despite the
sensible US move regrettably the direct
talks had gone nowhere so far and they
have become entwined in the separate
quests Larry said complete a separate
question or the fuel for the treeger
reactor a settlement of that limited
issue would ease tension somewhat but it
would in no way provide a solution to
the controversy about the
continuation of Iran's enrichment
program the compromise doesn't not
envisage a termination or suspension of
the big program it talks only about a
sort of swapping operation concerning a
quantity of low enriched uranium in
return for fuel for the research reactor
what non-military developments are
conceivable regarding the enrichment in
Iran an outside observer cannot detect
any movement in the deadlocked positions
of the negotiating governments on the
principle issue of enrichment if three
plus three plus hours insist on
suspension and most way there are first
and threats Iran insist on enrichment
that might be weighing the offers and
the threats that are made such as the
suspension sanctions that are ongoing
and they come more sanctions may come
they must weigh the possible
facilitation of financial transactions
investments that they will obtain if
they were to reach an agreement they
will weigh the assistance in the
development of peaceful nuclear power
which is also held out as a possibility
and a quid pro quo in case of the deal
and they were also weigh the promised
support for membership in the World
Trade Organization if they strike you to
you so these are chips on the table put
by the negotiating States it would not
be difficult to find add further
elements that could be offered to
influence the cost-benefit analysis
North Korea for instance appears to have
been offered diplomatic relations both
with the United States in Japan and been
offered guarantees against armed attacks
from the outside and subversion in the
inside now would such offers be
politically more difficult to make in
the case of Iran other chips on the
table could perhaps have regard to oil
and gas pipelines and there is kinds to
put it in cooperation for instance
regarding Afghanistan now some observers
say that Iran has come too far in the
nuclear progress process to retreat one
inch and that the world should accept
the Iranian in
judgment and only insist Iran accepting
what is demanded from other NPT states
namely the application of strength and
IAEA safeguards under the Additional
Protocol the NPT conference here in New
York which is ending this week seems not
to have dealt with ideas like these but
has focused on agreement on some future
procedures leading to discussions about
this middle-east
zone 3 or weapons a method of nuclear
weapons this of course was the way in
which Iran and Arab States used to urge
the elimination of Israeli nuclear
weapons today however the Iranian
enrichment program is a new element that
much increases the concerns of Arab
States a nuclear weapon-free zone alone
does not meet that problem nor for that
matter would be a test bank zone meet
that that problem the states in the
Middle East I believe would need to
supplement a nuclear weapon-free zone by
adding agreement to exclude enrichment
and reprocessing in the region at least
for prolonged period of time
north and south korea concluded such an
arrangement in the 1992 joint ik neuk
denuclearization so there is some
precedent for it if they did so of
course in order to increase the
confidence between the two that neither
of them would use such facilities for
the development of material for weapons
although such agreement would have
livesey Iran to dismantle its enrichment
program and Israel to dismantle both
weapons and enrichment and reprocessing
it would not be pointed to anyone but
ensure all in the region against
proliferation and be inlined with the
current efforts to avoid the spread of
fuel cycle activities of course in
today's atmosphere the idea is a
somewhat wild card it would have been
and would have to be developed inside
the region not least as regards
effective system of inspection in such
zone it is obviously way beyond what
Israel would contemplate today however
if both the peace process and the
Iranian program were to move on perhaps
Israel would one day conclude that the
arrangement would be better than a
Middle East with Iran and later perhaps
more States building enrichment plants
for plants and maybe weapons I remember
hearing the former US ambassador to the
UN mr. Bolton saying that his difference
his views on the nuclear weapon states
what nuclear weapon States that might be
in the world didn't differ very much
when President Obama you say President
Obama doesn't want to have one nuclear
weapon state note one zero I for my part
voters said I want only one and I think
they're similar with Israel has seen its
nuclear weapon program as the life
insurance they would like to have one
nuclear weapon state in the Middle East
but if they're the prospect in the
future were for more than one then
perhaps they would prefer to zero for
Iran such an arrangement of a zone of
free of nuclear weapons and a fuel cycle
facilities would have the cost of
scrapping an expensive enrichment
program that may of the prestige that no
economic advantage a note no no to long
term fuel assurance Iran would get the
credit for an elimination of nuclear
threats in the Middle East and the
ensuing day taunt would certainly allow
a reduction of the military expenditures
in the area now then let me make some
comments the Royale in North North Korea
and terrorist movements it seems to me
that in the last few years the great
powers have cooperated wisely regarding
the North Korea and while exerting
economic pressure had offered all that
the DPRK has asked for economic
assistance diplomatic relations security
assurances and maybe even a peace treaty
it is hard to conclude that the
intermittent backtracking and
stonewalling by North Korea could be a
way of seeking a better bargain than the
one they have been offered perhaps it is
a result of shifting portia positions of
factions within the leadership in the
North Korea or perhaps hardline military
in control want tension and controversy
to justify a continued hardship and
military rule these are speculations
admittedly not very many people who have
a clear insight into what's going on
there whatever may be the case it seems
wise for the outside world to avoid
being provoked still being within
artillery reach from North Korea
military action is not really an option
the recent torpedo of a South Korean
ship cannot of course be left without
response further economic pressures have
seemed the only option
and they also together with North
Korea's own failed system helped to
bring the regime down one day terrorist
movements are unable our we are believed
generally believed up they are unable to
to build enrichment capability regional
facilities are big and difficult and
expensive to do the likelihood that a
terrorist movement would be able to
steal and handle the real nuclear
weapons is judged also to be remote the
nunn-lugar program has been a remains of
the great value to put locks on nuclear
stocks and to reduce the number of sites
where weapons usable material is handled
it continues terrorist movements could
perhaps managed to make it dirty
so-called dirty bomb containing
radioactive material like cobalt or
cesium and set them off in some urban
area the recent Washington summit to
create awareness at the highest ledge
state levels of the need to keep track
of such material made much sense the
awareness this awareness should also be
created in the public if one can that
dirty bombs can cause radiation damage
that they are no no nuclear weapons they
are very far from nuclear weapons now
let me turn to nuclear disarmament when
in the spring of 2006 the weapons of
mass destruction Commission that I had
it presented its report on the outlook
for disarm that that the outlook for
disarmament was still dismal the US
national defense strategy of 2000
five had stated in all modesty I coached
at the end of the Cold War and our
capacity to influence global events
opened the prospects for a new and
peaceful system in the world that was in
2005 however by 2006 the Iraq war had
discredited this overconfidence in
military power and in January 2007
George Shultz and Henry Kissinger some
bill Perry and Sam Nam surprised the
world with an article in The Wall Street
Journal declaring that the Cold War was
over India in 1990 that deterrence was
obsolete between the US and Russia that
the big risk was proliferation by States
and rogue states and non-state actors
and that to prevent such proliferation
the US and Russia should initiate a
nuclear disarmament process that would
lead eventually to the elimination of
nuclear weapons they did not judge it
possible to continue with a system where
some had nuclear weapons and others
would stay without such weapons the
article consists contained the list of
actions needed in the short and medium
term and stressed the need to solve
regional disputes mr. Obama's remember
espoused this approach in his
presidential campaign and he and
president Nia dear death declared in
London that they would put an end put
the Cold War behind themselves to pursue
nuclear disarmament and even aim at the
nuclear weapon-free world in Prague then
in 1st of April 2009 President Obama
presented a long list of nuclear
disarmament measures many identical with
measures that have been advocated by the
Commission I headed and by the group of
the Gang of Four President Obama's and
program certainly contrasted starkly
with the attitudes of the Bush
administration yet this seems relative
the courses in my view when he declares
that he does not support unilateral
disarmament and that he doubts that
nuclear disarmament will get to global
zero
zone lifetime now he was given the Nobel
Prize for his initiatives and some
people were sarcastic about it and said
that he hadn't actually achieved any of
these are limited only talked about it
whether it occurred to me then that Al
Gore had also not stopped the global
warming but he had talked about it and
he has put it on the agenda and to put
something on the agenda - in the world
today is a very big thing and it has
remained on the agenda and this spring
certainly has been one in which we have
seen quite a number of steps in the
field of disarmament so in my view he
just did certainly deserve the Nobel
Prize very well but the big question is
now will the new approach and Drive of
the Obama administration helped to give
the world look for disarmament the
recent US Russia start follow-on
agreement is tangible result and creates
a springboard for further action will it
be ratified by a US Senate that does not
seem to be ready yet to ratify the
Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty we don't
know expectations and hope for it but no
certainty the recently published US
Nuclear Posture review that confirms the
serious push of the Obama administration
to reduce the role of nuclear weapons
for instance it rejects the construction
of any new type of nuclear weapons now
which are now the obstacles to nuclear
disarmament Hawks in the US and
elsewhere already focus on the end goal
of eliminating nuclear weapons and
charge that is naive as I mentioned the
world in the beginning it is a pity but
perhaps inevitable that attention is
focused on this point where the child
while the challenges today have regard
to issues like the entry into force of
the Comprehensive Test Ban Treaty and
the negotiation of a cutoff for
production of fissile material for
weapons if we ponder the chances of
phasing out nuclear weapons perhaps we
should begin by discussing what are
today the risks of war clearly after the
end of the Cold War
they have been sharply reduced since the
beginning of the
1990s Wars used to be about borders
about territory about religion or
ideology as during the cold war between
the big powers is hard to see such
conflicts any longer
China and India I trust will continue to
handle their border differences like
matically we can expect further civil
wars and there is likely to be armed
conflict in a few regions in particular
in Africa our borders are often not
settled there are also some flash points
that touch the interest of gay big
powers tyree and Taiwan and Kashmir and
the Middle East however they will hardly
ignite the world war and war between the
u.s. and Mexico are you had wars in the
past that won't be any in the future war
in there lacked in America South America
region hardly within the European Union
no not after the creation of the
European Union and between Asian states
partly good competition about oil and
gas and other commodities and pipelines
trigger war well I wonder does not seem
more likely that such frictions will
play out in crisis despite this hopeful
outlook many military officials and
people dealing with military strategy in
the US and elsewhere urge their
governments to maintain high military
readiness and pay anything between two
and four percent of the GDP for such
readiness while in the US the Gang of
Four said that deterrence was obsolete
between the US Russia and Russia and our
diminishing importance in other
relations the recent US Nuclear Posture
review certainly is holding on to the
importance of deterrence this position
must be premised on the view that the
risk of big armed conflict is still real
is this view justified his work
plausible between p5 states but the Gang
of Four seems to doubt it and so do i
and some people may perhaps say that
this is romantic attitude and I remember
the Swedish saying that when the devil
gets old he becomes religious well I
think that they are
come wise and mature they were lived
through the Cold War as I did and I
think that they is maturity that they
have come to and I'm glad they did we
often hear from the big powers that they
do not consider each other as
adversaries any longer but are concerned
rather about terrorists and a few
irresponsible governments now if so why
acquire new aircraft carriers space
fighting capabilities why allow the
world to use one thousand four hundred
billion dollars a year on military items
after which new American citizens are
paying forty five percent the reason
must be that for now the skeptical
voices are prevailing in the United
States and elsewhere and people in the
US and elsewhere are are buying this
cautious attitude can we accelerate that
movement towards nuclear disarmament I
think so and I think the reset recipe is
diplomacy and the further deterrent
we need to continue resetting many
buttons let us be clear that the new
start agreement would hardly have been
reached had President Obama not moved
the missile shield links from Poland and
the Czech Republic we need more for such
constructive thinking and let me give
you some examples of that if as we are
told the missile shield is not meant to
protect the United States against Russia
and China but against reckless
governance why not create it
cooperatively between the US Europe
Russia and China and I'm encouraged by
recent talks between the NATO
organization and Russia in Europe
nuclear weapons under NATO command
appear to be a relic of the Cold War why
not withdraw them they have in my view
being long being the low-hanging fruit
it is true that Russia has no veto
against the security arrangements of its
neighbors but it's also understandable
that they taunt with Russia will not be
promoted if Nate the NATO alliance is
moving up military coordination
listening devices and weapons
to the borders differences between the
big powers cannot be overcome by the
creation of new blocks but must be
tackled by conciliation cooperation and
the development of joint institutions
fortunately the accelerating
international interdependence will force
everybody in this direction and is
already doing so the UN's
United Nations system is a major
instrument to be used and developed
rather than being disdain as much my
countrymen dog commercial once said and
I would add one quote to your summary
you say advance that it might the UN
system might not take us to heaven but
it might help us to avoid going to hell
well Hans Blix has kindly agreed to
participate in the questions and answer
session so whoever wants to ask a
question question on when they're mean
many very important issues that you you
have addressed and so the floor is open
yes yes
yeah I'm Rhonda haben and I cover I've
been covering the UN fair yes if you
when you speak if you can identify and
yourself as you do and your organization
and I've been watching the Security
Council what they've been doing with
Iran and North Korea and I guess I'm
very troubled by what you presented
about both Iran and North Korea it seems
to me the the non-proliferation treaty
provides for the inalienable right to
for peaceful production of nuclear
materials or whatever and it just it's
clear that that is a right of Iran there
has been no proof of Iran doing
something of weapons and it just seemed
and when you present it you made it seem
like there is proof there is no proof
and somehow the treaty guarantees the
right to that that inalienable right it
says nothing on the treaty shall be done
to take that away and yet the Security
Council he is under the name of the
treaty taking that away and there's
there's some sort one that I think
that's very serious to Iran has a long
history of having trouble getting the
materials that other countries can get
and that it's had sanctions from the US
since 79 in all kinds of ways and so I
just feel you left out that whole
history and and made the assumption Iran
is is doing what what people who seem to
want to prevent the inalienable right if
you are using using the treaty so I'm
one of them troubled by that because it
seems a second example of what happened
with Iraq has happening with Iran and
then there's North Korea and North Korea
if people who specialize in North Korea
and many of the books show that the US
has has gone back on every commitment
that's made to North Korea and that
there was exactly they were in with so
that there's somehow a whole history
with North Korea where is it is in a
very threatening citrix threatened
situation there's a nuclear umbrella
against it from both with the u.s. to
South Korea into Japan and so it just
seems to fit more in the category of a
nation that feels itself that threat and
so I don't understand your examples of
the two of them as as you know and as
being and so I just after you've been
through that incredible experience with
Iraq where this was a a very you know
this was real trouble with what was done
with the rack can we learn something
about it so I don't understand perhaps I
wasn't sufficiently clear but I thought
I said that the security cause no one
else has said that Iran has violated the
non-proliferation treaty I didn't say
that I said that even some of the
evidence brought against Iran might not
be well-founded but there is enough to
cause a large number of government be
suspicious that Iran has the intention
to go for nuclear weapons that is the
background saying that the case has been
proved and I also made it clear that yes
to see NPT allows the state to enrich
uranium but there the fact that there
doesn't seem to be an economic case for
enrichment that is not a solution
long-term solution for Iran for fuel
assurance because the Iran does not
according to according to
the Asians have very much rule uranium
in its ground so then it's natural that
the outside world awesome cell why does
it do this and they haven't said they
violated but they offer Iran a number of
the Adid we're the number of chips on
the table and I think some of them are
are useful and notably they are not
denying Iran going for nuclear power I
could have expected perhaps that would
happen but that's not the case the
outside world any offers have been to
support that peaceful nuclear power
program building nuclear power reactors
it is only concern that a program for to
build facilities for the enrichment of
uranium which could go up to
weapons-grade which iran denies they has
intention to do but i think it's very
important very important to note that
the outside world is not in against a
modernization or in iran's entry into
the modern technology and the russians
of course are helping them to build the
Butcher reactors and and that is
accepted by the outside world now offer
iran there are those who think that iran
has come so far that they would not
there's no chance that they will back
down that is a it's possible but the
there is nothing in the in the NPT that
would prevent them from striking iran is
sometimes saying that the NPT allows us
it to rich uranium fine but there's no
obligation to do so if they would like
to strike a deal they could and i think
is for them to way to make the
cost-benefit analysis in this night hope
they do now i don't think that iran
necessarily has gone so far that there's
no way back we have the world that
doesn't lack nuclear installations which
have been abandoned so argentina for
instance have enrichment plant up in
pill can you I've seen it myself and if
they are not using it south africa it's
not to my knowledge using the enrichment
plant at the moment which they could
certainly assert that they have a right
to do brazil does although it's a part
of the NPT japan has also written
richmond plants and they they certainly
have a use for I don't see any
impossibility in it but it may be that
they determined that this is a question
of pride and of prestige and they could
invoke I think the fact that they were
denied they had a great difficulty in
getting a fuel for the treeger reactor
quite a number of years ago after the
religious revolution they and they had
placed an order for the few new fuel in
the United States for this new us-made
reactor and they they paid for it
they got neither the money back you
wanted to get the fuel and eventually
they were able to buy fewer from
Argentina so this I think they could
invoke and say that look we are we need
our to assure fuel ourselves and I think
that when the Western world is
discussing now fuel for the troopers
reactor they could also tell us also
tell themselves that look if we simply
say they cannot have any fuel for this
trigger act unless they suspend the only
Richmond program the Iran could respond
that look there you are we need to have
her home program otherwise we cannot
even have fuel for our or reactor but
this is a separate issue and I think if
Pratt made a bit too much of it at the
present time the central question
remains after they continued enrichment
program in Iran and the way I saw or the
way I sketch a solution was it somewhat
far-reaching and then an idea that goes
much beyond what is on the table
anywhere now namely that they you should
have not only a zone free of nuclear
weapons which would apply to Israel to
do away with its nuclear but it would
also would exclude any enrichment plants
and reprocessing transyl that's
precisely what they Korea to korean
states that agree this would be the
ideal solution but we are far from that
today and i think i am for israel i
think it would be out of question to
consider that present time however if
Israel were to see that the evolution
were towards more enrichment in the
Middle East then perhaps they would
contemplated but it's it's not solution
for today I thought it was a fairly
it is a fairly balanced evaluation I'm
sorry if you had the impression that
that I was standing on
I can see both there the the weaknesses
of audience from all the sites and the
weaknesses in the negotiation have taken
place so far now in North Korea you were
mentioned again of course the North
Korea what it encouraged me is that I
say what encouraged me is about Iran is
first of all I don't see that there
really is a threat to their security any
longer in my assessment they began
exploring the program in Richmond at the
time when there was the war between the
Iraq and Iran and at the time of the
Israelis bombed video see right reacted
1981 they might well have fear that Iran
Iraq would go on and that they are there
for security reasons began today I do
not see that Iran realistically have any
in its big security cell third not from
Pakistan from Turkey but Afghanistan
maybe from the US aircraft carriers in
the Gulf but they know at the same time
that this is threat from the US and from
Israel is only there so long as there is
enrichment program so the reactions of a
serious threat probe to Iran I think
there ought to be increase the chances
of some agreement now in case of North
Korea again I think security
considerations originally moved them
towards nuclear weapon program the u.s.
commanders in the Korean War in 1950
asked for authorization to use nuclear
weapons they thought that they take off
the authorization but in any case it was
not used fortunately so they moved on
and what give some hope I think for a
solution there was that after the 90s
for quite a number of years they stopped
the reprocessing plant after a visit by
mr. Carter and I think that had a
psychological effect of such a visit was
very important and was a former US
president that came to North Korea met
with Kim Kim in a song and the upgrading
the recognition that here was a country
that needed courtesy and correctness at
any rate this I think was was important
so for a number of years they stopped
the reprocessing and our inspectors from
the IAEA were there to inspect their
reprocessing cloud but we have to
admit that at some stage during this
period they also began to him to him
with enrichment and that did collide at
least for the 1992 denuclearization
agreement so while there was acceptance
and implementation of one agreement
nevertheless there was something that
happened in in the background and that
was not a straightforward respect of
their agreement so I'm not surprised
that you had that there was then they
clash and I don't think this clash was
happened very well on the western side
all the time they I'm not saying that
but nevertheless that's the background I
think that North Korea has a good deal
of responsibility for the situation
where they are and I think that the
present time the outside world is
handling it rather well with the wisdom
it's very difficult to see any solution
as I said I think North Korea has in
fact been offered with practically
everything I cannot see that they are
that they are trying to to increase to
get the better deal any longer they're
getting what they are asking for that's
why I'm speculating what why are they
delimits is this a result of jockeying
positions within the North Korean regime
or is it that there isn't it's a
military regime in control is it due to
the fact that they say that we want to
attention we want around our country
that will justify continued military
stances in our reality in control these
are speculations but well this is right
or not in any case I think that the
patients and they not allowing myself to
provoked is their right one they had to
respond of course to torpedo
oh such a great thing they must
have written there must be a response to
it but nevertheless I think it's wise
and it's an encouragement that you have
all the p5 members on the same line here
and of course they would have to aim in
the long run for some sort of security
arrangement in the Far East in that
corner of the world
yes over there
I write for the oh my news in South
Korea occasionally but just very briefly
on September 19 205 the six-party talks
did arrange for the suspension of all
activity nuclear activities in the
beginning of the process of
denuclearization and on the next day
over the next two days sank economic
sanctions were put against North Korea
sabotaging the very agreement that
happened on the 19th by the 20th 21st
the Banco Delta Asia in Macau is being
attacked by economically so North Korea
has a long set of examples when it does
come to agreement it makes its agreement
it had the agreed-upon framework all
during the 90s and it's always somehow
broken before it gets a chance to break
it so North Korea has has to be
reluctant I think to take the deal
because it's taking it a number of times
and it hasn't worked out as I said I'm
not suggesting that the negotiation has
been ideal all the time on the western
side certainly not but there remains the
fact that that while there was an
agreement in 1994 and that was respected
as regarding reprocessing there was a
movement by North Korea to go to
enrichment and that does certainly not
suggest much a reliance on them I think
that the patience that's now being shown
is exemplary I also don't think that
when they talk about anything about
dangers to that country I could see that
they would identify the Bush
administration as a rather threatening
administration but I find it very hard
to believe that they really think that
the Obama administration was more
threatening than the Bush administration
my name's Alfred Ross
gratulations on the launching of the
Saltzman Institute it's a marvelous
addition to Columbia and you've chosen a
superb director who I've known for many
years and a wonderful speaker on Iran if
it's true as you suggest that Iran under
NPT has a legal right to enrich
whether or not it's economically
feasible what is the legal basis for the
UN Security Council demand that they
cease enrichment and as a international
matter of international law can the
Security Council by demanding that they
see what they have a legal right to do
does that automatically become law that
they must see in other words is there
any legal basis for the Security Council
demand if there's no legal basis for the
demand that they cease enrichment is
there any legal basis for new sanctions
well the non-proliferation treaty gives
the right to use nuclear techniques
including a which meant to developed
peaceful nuclear power but of course if
there is a question whether is peaceful
and it can be argued that the right
disappears I don't think I don't agree
where there was a claim that is
therefore fitting the right so that's
expression has been used I think that's
going too far but I can see the the
basis in in this statement that we have
reasons to believe that this is not
peaceful and we ask you to to show the
credibility that the program is peaceful
and there are elements in that program
which
and the program with certain cost doubt
about the intention but I agree with you
that it began as a suggestion of demand
of Iran to suspend as a
confidence-building measure that was how
it began go to the IEA and I think in
the Security Council and when that
didn't help them that went on my
recollection with the use of chapter 7
and they a mandatory decision that they
must suspend one can have on stood about
doubts about that
the fact is nevertheless that the
Security Council's decisions demands in
this kind are binding there is no appeal
court to it we cannot go to the
International Court of Justice and say
that this is not reasonable it's the
council that that decides and one would
have expected that members within the
council if some of the members had
doubts about the legal wisdom organized
that they would have be active but you
find here soon as you find the fight for
members doing it so I do not I would not
advocate or argue that these decisions
are not binding
it may be unwise if you ask for if the
Security Council asked for more than we
can get then it's the respect for the
council may go down but I would not dare
as a lawyer to argue that these are not
not finding I think I think this council
also went further and said that they
would be ready to discuss with with Iran
conditions once Iran has suspended the
Richmond program and that was in line
with the position of the US and other
other states that first they must
suspend thereafter we can talk and I was
very curious to see what would happen
with mr. Obama's stand that they can he
could talk directly which I welcomed I
feel that was good and I thought what
don't they have somehow to modify the
position of the Security Council
here is an order as that you shall
suspend thereafter will talk but they
simply ignored it invented the direct
talks and I think perhaps just as well
but but nevertheless that
that was the result that I think Obama's
sensible policy of getting to direct
talks they may be resumed but now that
now I think we are in the distraction of
the particular program about the treeger
reactor if you will it's made a big
thing and I think if it were to the
solvent
I think Turkey and Brazil deserves
praise for it if it succeeds then I
think it will ease tensions on what it
will show that if all parties are ready
to make some concession you can have
some result if it fails well then it
will exacerbate the situation even
further make the atmosphere even more
even world picture yes the gentleman in
the back
hey Adam Peoria he's covering this for
the Columbia record that was a very
sober and non hysterical talk and made
me feel better living in New York City
about the possibility of nuclear bombs
exploding here but I just wanted to know
what keeps you up at night you know I
mean you're talking about
non-proliferation but what do you see is
the greatest threat the greatest you
know if there was gonna be some sort of
nuclear calamity where is it most likely
to come from even taking into account
that it's unlikely what is the most
dangerous class I think we are
discussing the case where it could be
most immediate and that's in North
Korean maybe they have the nuclear
weapons and they have tested the nuclear
weapons I don't think it's very likely
that they would use it against anybody I
think see the greatest fear who I have
good habits that they would sell nuclear
technology to somebody but I don't see
any sign of that I don't feel
particularly reassured by the
coordination of Security Initiative that
will stop ships I mean five kilograms of
petunias about the size of my hands I
don't think you need a big cargo ship to
export that anywhere but it's not not
without the danger know as you say I
mean I more in trying to calm the visit
I don't agree with the idea of cascades
it's it's not the world is not without
risks in this regard but I it gives very
good headlines any more anything along
this gives very great headlines and I'm
I'm interested in in seeing how can we
calm down the is it something bizarre
about the nuclear the about in military
expenses of the world being 1400 billion
dollars a year at the present time I saw
an editorial in The Herald Tribune the
other day in which they praised your
Secretary of Defense whom I think it's a
very sensible balanced person that he's
holding back the military expenses they
they were about 4% addition in real
terms increase until until he got there
now he's trying to hold them down to
between two and three percent in real
terms increases well at the time when
there is there talent in the world so my
answer is how can we can we make this
process
faster to decelerate and my answer to
that is diplomacy I think that if you
have more calm then then it is easier
also to say that we don't need all this
readiness you don't need to add more
aircraft carriers to meet the danger of
non-state actors you don't need to add a
tremendous amount of space fighting
capability for al-qaeda the military
strategists I think are saying that yes
there is still a risk of war between p5
it's receding but nevertheless how long
are we going to pay these levels and and
I think that that the levels can go down
if we have more diplomacy and more
resetting on the buttons and I think
that the although of Ahmad station says
that the movement of the missile links
from Poland Czech Republic was were
justified and motivated by other things
than a deterrent with Russia
nevertheless that was an effect I mean I
was being to Moscow recently and I I see
how much they resented these things it
was not that they felt threatened that
the US would be able to attack Russia
and the Russia would not be able to take
they know but they resented this sort of
intrusion on their doorstep they felt
that was not very elegant
euphemistically and similarly in Russia
you you find the idea of expansion of
NATO into the Ukraine and Georgia was
also something they say okay they decide
their own security relations we have no
veto in this regard but don't expect
that we that the ATandT will increase
fight after when the Cold War ended the
Warsaw Pact was dissolved from what
happened but a number of the Warsaw Pact
members immediately went over to the
native text and I can understand that
they have been occupied by the Soviet
Union a reality so I can understand them
but it was not anything that was
designed to further the day tones
between Russia and the Western world now
after the Georgian affair I don't think
in the western states there is any wish
to have at least George as a member of
NATO because
really in my view and many others view a
solid red chilly and to have a reckless
leader in the native state perhaps
attracting sort of Russia a Russian
attacks would not be a very good thing
because they would be obliged
collectively to intervene so they going
away from that I think is what is good I
don't think that Obama station has
declared that that's the purpose but
it's clear that the European states are
not going to be more in favor of adding
Ukraine and Georgia if you look at the
election campaign there I think Obama
was in favor of supported the idea of
expansion of NATO with Ukraine I don't
think as you heard descended from but if
you look at what mr. McCain said he was
advocating the idea of a league of
democratic states and all states
including these former Soviet states
they could be members if they were
democratic and willing they could be
members of it and that to me sounded
like setting up two sort of alternative
the UN an organization of friends which
could perhaps legitimize a use of force
which they would not get through the
Security Council because there is a veto
in the Security Council
well the idea collapsed and I think it
rightly should collapse but to Russia it
must have seemed that that the u.s.
wanted to move towards a new policy of
containment with say the Western world I
take off my hat toward NATO or the
containment policy achieved but I think
after the end of the Cold War I don't
think it's the right policy and it seems
to me that the US and the West now are
all ready to to lower the tension by
discussing with Russia a the security
architecture in Europe only a few days
ago mr. Biden you're right the president
wrote a very long very detailed article
about the further reconciliation
forbidden did talk between us and the
Western Europe on the one hand and rush
on the other I think it's very
constructive he did not accept the idea
that there would be a new security
organization God knows that there are
enough security structures about Europe
already but he pointed rather to the
idea that the Organization for Security
Cooperation in Europe which is located
Vienna that more life would be blown
into it and it was a willingness to
discuss security between Russia and the
United States and these two straits
after all are the ones I had by thought
and largest number of nuclear weapons in
the world so they they are very
important but you cannot also ignore the
Chinese because they are growing very
fast I was in Shanghai and Beijing and
only ten days ago and you see the
tremendous vigor with which they are
moving ahead fortunately so far without
weather rather control nationalism it's
not allowed than risk nationalist but I
think it requires pragmatic attitudes
and and Concilium attitudes to bring
this world to a more cooperation more
use of multilateral institutions than
where we had certainly had during the
Bush administration
yes
hi I'm Gerald staying I'm a recent
graduate here a quick question about
Iran and I guess Israel you you spoke
about how it's essential for
non-proliferation efforts to address the
security questions of individual states
and for Iran I was hoping to get your
idea of their perceptions of Israel and
how central that is to their calculus as
opposed to other things in the area and
connecting a little bit the political
and legal sides of the calculus how
Israel could be incentivized to
potentially change its approach to the
legal status of its weapons and whether
if Israel would change how it approaches
nuclear issues whether that could have
an impact back towards Iran well that's
my speculation I don't see any sign of
it at all today government is fairly
focus on the issue but I don't think
it's democratic state there are many
different views in that that country
that was the different views about what
they should do elsewhere the calculus in
calculation I have is that if if Iran's
program moves on I'm not saying I want
that but if it moves on and if at the
same time there is some opening towards
the peace process in Israel then it
would seem to me that there would be the
possibility of discussing doing the way
for Israel to do away with the nuclear
weapons and at the same time the Iran
and others committing themselves to
having no fuel cycle activities I mean
there is a general driver wish in the
world to have fewer fuel cycle
activities because each of these
facilities make it physically possible
again ready if not not in politically
possible to produce nuclear weapon
material so it is in line with that
general drive but there is no opening to
it at the moment themselves presumably
look upon the their nuclear weapons as
the life insurers but let me remind you
that when the program was a rich
launched there was no enthusiasm about
it in the Western world or the United
States is gradually being sort of
acquiescence that it is there but but no
no no if you says know about this or no
and Israeli that's not is not a naked
without nuclear weapons
they are the formatively armed with
conventional weapons so it's not that
they would stand there exposed to being
being attacked by the others however I'm
not suggesting that you need a security
arrangement for it it may be that such a
zone will require security guarantees
from the outside certainly we require
guarantees about the access and
availability to for nuclear fuel for the
reactors but also security guarantees
and they I think Israel already has more
than an alliance with the United States
so they feel secure but if if they both
wanted to maybe like a rule to be
Security Ganges through multilateral
kind for the Security Council and why
not contemplate having Israel in them as
a member of NATO
if Albania can be a member of NATO and
eastern Mediterranean why not is respect
if that could help but the point my
point is simply that yes you have to
supplement such arrangement with also
security guarantees
I'm on Pakistan um do you think that
concerning India is signed on to a non
first strike policy that you identify
yourself oh yeah I'm Stephen Bronstein
I'm a student at Franklin and Marshall
College so concerning India signed on to
a non first strike policy do you think
pecks Ian's over assesses it's perceived
threat over against India both nuclear
Lee and militarily over Kashmir and do
you think that detracts from their
counterterrorism capabilities well I'm
not very hopeful about any arrangement
between is true between India and
Pakistan unless they move forward on the
Kashmir's yes you the political
realities I think they push in both in
good and bad directions and what I'm not
an expert on that question but what I
hear from many people is that seems that
both sides are know fairly well watch
what should be the solution it's like
the Israeli president Palestinians
people know what should be the solution
but they can't get that the same thing
with a Kashmir is here that they know
where to go and I think the US can play
a good role and probably does play a
good role there because the US has
established some strategic relation with
with India and at the same time very
dependent upon its relationship Pakistan
so I think it's probably one case where
the u.s. is helpful I have a question
related to that there was when you you
mentioned how successful the NPT has
been and there are very few nuclear
powers that emerged after the NPT India
and Pakistan are - outside the NPT there
was recently when it was initiated by
the Bush administration were confirmed
by the Obama administration and nuclear
deal how do you see the impact I think
he was very negative I mean I don't
think that it was
if a violation of the NPT because the
NPT says that the exchange of Technology
and the transfer technology should be
facilitated to be imparted to the entity
but it does not prohibit the transfer of
Technology the non-member to the NPT so
it was not a violation of this unless
one can point and show that this
facilitates for India to to proliferate
to make more nuclear weapons the
allegations that this can happen because
it did mention that that the India has
little uranium of its own and if they
are able to import fuel well then they
can also use their own indigenous
uranium to reach it to a higher level to
through weapons-grade so on that basis
it could be a could be argued that the
deal with India actually was a violation
of the u.s. obligation to refrain from
proliferation by helping India I I have
another greater concern about that
agreement and that is I don't think if
this all was was motivated by by the
Bush administration by a wish to achieve
nuclear cooperation I think that the
intention was and it was stated by
political leaders the intention was to
improve and so to create a strategic
liaison between India between the United
States and India in an effort to build
some kind of a a chain around China with
India Australia Japan South Korea that
was also stated and I have the same
reservations about that as I have about
building a new containment policy
deserve a Russia I think fortunately I
don't I haven't seen any very negative
comments from the Chinese side they have
been their restrained
I'm and it may oh I don't think
necessarily the Indians will allow
themselves to be involved in a chain
against China they probably want to
retain their freedom nor do I know
whether Australia would like to do so
the intent was certainly on the side of
the Bush administration to create such a
new containment policy and that in my
view is is not a policy for this this
millennium I think the policy for this
millennium is to bring them all in to a
multilateral cooperation in
international institutions so I have
serious reservations about it though I
do and it's also undermined the on
privation policy in the sense that they
that it certainly went against the the
agreements under the Nuclear Suppliers
group because Nuclear Suppliers group is
they didn't within the nuclear supplies
that they will not export any nuclear
material or technology to conscious they
don't have full scope safeguards and
that's a full scope safe because it's
what you have and you are party to the
MTT in India evidently didn't have that
so if they had to ask for an exception
in the nucleus of the US had to ask for
an exception in Nuclear Suppliers group
and there were a number of states who
will oppose to ask questions New Zealand
Austria Denmark Sweden but but the
pressure of big United States was so
great that they will give it a way and
in China to who had perhaps reasons to
worry about this they also didn't object
maybe they felt that if the u.s. can do
that to India then we can delete to
Pakistan
that's the possibility that this was the
calculation but it was certainly a
deviation from the joint determination
of the Nuclear Suppliers group not to
facilitate any and it further build up a
nuclear weapon so I think it was
reprehensible and unwise from many
points of view but that seems to be a
fairly popular he was Congress even my
Democrats I do not see any previous
model
Larry Johnson I'm teaching at Columbia
attention and some of that of course has
been the risk that al Qaeda or some
terrorist groups I'm thinking of that in
terms of Pakistan as well in terms of
what you do when you have a nuclear
power whose government may be weak or
shaky you have that in North Korea to
some extent but in Pakistan you have the
crossroads of terrorism Pakistan Taliban
extremist groups perhaps radical
military what is the safety are there
any plans or anything you can think of
to make sure that either their nuclear
facilities are under control and not
subject to being raided or being sold to
al-qaeda I think is a very troubling
question that you raised the sometimes
we read him in the papers that Pentagon
certainly has a plan B somewhere
whatever it is but I don't think that's
very easy at all the what I would think
is that the tradition of troll is in
Pakistan that the military and the last
resort has a very good control and that
is what the US military seem to say that
we are confident that the Pakistan the
military in command that they also have
control of the weapons in the stores and
I hope that's justified but I think it's
troublesome especially if you say if you
were to have a radicalization element
among the military it's it's not without
very unpleasant risks you can paint and
I think the North Korea's is probably a
different element that's less danger but
in Pakistan we can see the from the
group
fighting each other well again in the
longer term I think it is the Kashmir
issue it's between India and Pakistan I
don't think that India would go for
disarmament before I'm except to do it
in tandem with the other nuclear weapon
states it's not going to happen before
that but so long as they have Kashmir as
if pestering issue of history issue it's
going to be very very difficult and for
the immediate future the next time
though I don't see any any safe solution
to the problem
my name is Paul titled I'm a Columbia
student adequate measures for
inspections to guarantee that peaceful
use is being adhere to is Iran
cooperating with inspections and if they
are not or if any nation is not does
that void their right to enrich uranium
well I thank you for the question
because I touched on verification very
lightly in my introduction perhaps you
would expect me have having been the
head of the IAEA for 16 years in the
charge of arak inspections I should
touch upon it more
well the inspection was something that
became necessary when the world decided
that the way to to counter nuclear
weapons to was to avoid any possession
of them when you only had a ban on
chemical weapons
the band was against the use it was not
against possession but the moment you
say that that we commit ourselves not to
possess it well then you have to ensure
also that it that this is is confident
that its credibility this even in
peacetime and the only way to do that
was to have inspectors however the world
is not has not been used to having
inspectors milling around in important
industrial installations and therefore
there was a lot of resistance to go that
far
originally the NPT had its edge perhaps
more against Germany against Japan
against country just relized countries
like Sweden and Austria who might be
tempted to go for nuclear weapons and
the the risk of cheating or hiding
something in these countries is very
small so the demand for very intrusive
inspections or and far-reaching rights
and inspectors these demands are not
very strong and they got a system then
accepted which
allowed for checking that there was no
diversion from dick shared facilities
but there was no right for inspectors to
go to norm declared facilities nor would
they have known where they should go
because we have no intelligence
apparatus who would go around and going
into big countries and searching at
random was not meaningful so it was a
limited system and it was only when we
our inspectors went into Charmeleon Iran
Iraq in 1991 and and saw the Calot rods
that we they call the Baghdad trance
they they were American can across from
California then then we went to the
board of the IAEA and said that our
system has failed to discover this they
were working on this during the 80s and
our system was not strong enough to
discover it because we only went to
declared installations this was never
declared so we need another system under
which the inspectors can also demand to
go elsewhere and the declared
inspirations and we will also say we
would like to turn to intelligence and
say if you know if you have suspicious
tell us because we have the right to go
anywhere would that with the right to go
anywhere
under the new system well we undertook a
number of changes that we could do
without asking for approval of member
governments was they in our in our
existing capability but to get much
further we need it also to draw up the
protocol which under which governments
would give the IAEA much further right
so we started that in 1993 and it wasn't
ready until I left the ia 1997 when it
was adopted by consensus by our General
Conference and I was very happy with
that result and it is a it is a
considerable strengthening of the
safeguard system of the ability of the
inspectors and also the techniques of
inspection and verification had improved
very much much thanks to US assistance
where they have worked very much since
sandy and other places for instance take
take the example of environmental
sampling as it's called now and then run
the nuclear you don't see you can't
smell the radiation a nuclear
but instruments I can pick them up very
very easily leaves fingerprints
tremendous there and they you can might
remember that from the in the beginning
of the array Iraqi crisis the Iraqis to
custody so there to course a number of
American hostage place them in there
into ITER which was their nuclear center
and then the hostages were released at
that point and when the American
hostages came out they gave their
clothes to their secret services and
they analyzed the clothes and they were
tiny particles there aha
they are dealing with enrichment so very
tiny things to discover and this
technique has then been refined and
developed you can take take samples of
water or biota or a van air and you can
detect a high they are doing something
here so the techniques have gone far
beyond the satellites the surprise of
course remains very important but the
techniques of in my mental sampling is
very good so the whole system is more
sensitive than to discover that I would
not say that is a hundred percent and
you think we as a suspected me in the
Iraq affair we got a lot of praise and
said I am people come to me and say that
well you were right you told that there
were no weapons we did not say so
we said we are carried out seven hundred
inspections in five hundred different
sites we had been to some three dozens
of sites given to us by intelligence and
nowhere did we find any weapons of mass
destruction and we were ready to go on
and continue with this but the point is
that you it's very hard to prove the
negative and if we were to come to say
that we were on balance we don't think
there's a thing then the Bush
administration British to probably what
it comes to have you looked here have
you looked there how can you say this
this is this is not responsible so
that's not what the inspectors do and
they cannot do any can you should be
absolutely sure that's not a little
mouse somewhere here in this room
proving the negative it's pretty hard so
that will remain in the future I don't
think that you can't come to a hundred
percent assurance there will always be a
little residue of uncertainty it doesn't
mean that inspection is meaningless on
the country the more you do the more
professional
they're less the residuary of
uncertainty but that last step is a
political decision say yes there's a
researcher we judged the situation can
we live with this residual and the world
did that does regard South Africa we did
a very extensive investigation South
Africa and suggested that South Africa
had dismantled everything we didn't say
that is nothing but we said this is what
we've done and the world has such a
confidence and okay we will act upon
this we accept we swallow that residual
and I think that's how it will be in the
future as well that there will be a
residual but it still calls for all the
possible and reasonable system of
inspection though you have to regard
yourself it's at one risk and those
false alarms if you have a system of
inspection verification that is too
sensitive you may have false alarms
coming off and that is also can also be
very very troublesome in international
relations so it's in it's not a simple
problem I'm glad you raised it wasted
and I think that the world has come a
long way and I don't think you will
stand in the way of of disarmament you
see over we here said that how can you
guarantee that not somewhat somebody
will not have some bombs left in some
cave somewhere in the world in the
future well the systems in 20 30 years
from now with even better than our
countries will be more open also to
inspection yet the the world will be
different in twenty thirty years time
from it is now as I said the world with
free of nuclear weapons will not be the
world of today - nuclear weapons we will
have security systems that have moved
much forward will be much more it
dependent upon each other and therefore
I think that the conclusion that we can
live with the residual will be less
difficult than many people to presume
now the one last question lady
I'm Mickey Kaufman undergraduate with
the school of general studies here at
Columbia
we've been you've been talking a lot and
we've been asking a lot of questions
about compelling the behavior of North
Korea of Iran and other countries seen
to be in violation to whatever extent of
this nuclear non-proliferation I'd like
to ask you essentially question that you
asked in your own book which is how can
we make sure that the unilateral actions
of the United States in the Iraq
invasion have not created a riskier
situation in essence compelling Iran and
North Korea to hurry up their nuclear
programs in an attempt to outwit counter
proliferation what sanctions or steps or
evolution in American behavior in
foreign policy are required to stabilize
the situation well essentially I I agree
with the European doctrine which I read
to you that you have two countries in
most cases go for nuclear weapons for
secure perceived security reasons not in
there if yeah I'm not sure about Qaddafi
or about Saddam Hussein in this regard
but in most cases it's it's a perceived
security and therefore you have to cater
for their security and I think that
raising the voice or threatening is is
not a very helpful inducement yes I mean
if you have economic sanctions maybe
inducement but if they go too far then
maybe had the contrary effect and I
think the discussion about sanctions
economic sanctions against Iran very
telling I mean the public often say
absolutely more so in Europe than in the
US than Europe they say well if they
don't do what I say we will punish them
but I think that is often more more
likely that you get results if you offer
rewards and if you offer security and
the North Koreans happy not for security
I agree with the comments we had here
about Macau I may be that the measures
they took there on the financial side
have some inducement but also risky
wanna cause I've been provoking the one
has to be very careful in the
calibration of is the public does not
the public say no no they are not saying
doing as we say so we have to punish
them straight away and but I think that
the foreign ministers will know that no
this may not be so you had a big
discussion as to whether one should stop
or the delivery of gasoline to Iran
France and that would be a fairly big
thing but many have said that it will
hit the general public and it may well
be that I will support the
administration that Medina that will
achieve a rallying around his regime
rather than anything else so it's not as
simple as simply simply knocking
somebody you have to be sophisticated
about it and and on the whole creating
feeling of perceived security yes I
think they're trying to do that with
North Korea they are off of this and
therefore it's bit puzzling that they do
not succeed and that's why I'm
speculating at I don't think anyone else
is coming up with in and the other
solution for North Korea as regards to
Iran which there's prestige in this yes
that's a press to find the last word
that offer that is I think that
humiliation
among states is a very very bad thing
and if you are big and strong and expect
to be respected then humiliating and
saying you say uncle first this is
perhaps very natural but very in
productive and it will remind many of
these days about the colonialist time
when they were told to behave themselves
and treating them even the word behaved
has been used I remember it couldn't
live Ric was the one saying they should
behave themselves well that's the way
you talk to Colin isn't and to children
but to do it whatever you think about
the government you are talking to you
better use it quite correctly okay well
I just want to thank you again thank you
all for coming Thank You Hans Blix for
inaugurating this series
thank you very much